but yeah after you sit in coach like I I
now I sometimes if I can't afford it
because they'll be like hey you know
it's it's an extra thousand then I'll be
like all right I'll go to business yeah
Stacey will kill me right now because
when I go to cities I buy sneakers right
right no you're a problem with spending
sometimes you like to treat yourself
well oh dude
you're like a hat a new hat every now
and then Bill Burr and Pete David Sego I
just all we want for Izzy to get rich
because we'll see what he does yeah I
told my wife I want a horse I want a
horse you will dress like these hype
beasts out here you have like a two
thousand dollar hoodie no Tim you're
gonna come to my house instead you're
sitting on a white horse yeah I really
want like I want you to feed it away
Italians when Italians succeed this is
what they do yeah like an exotic animal
I get that white white things and I want
one some weird cat yeah yeah dude it's
funny you said that I was actually
asking Stacy if she wanted to get a lynx
yeah yeah no no I want white marble
everywhere yeah I want white marble
everywhere fish tank
a little fish tank Giannis redid his
basement yeah and when you sit on
giannis's couch downstairs to the to the
left yeah you can see and it's all white
marble and I stare at it like like a fly
to a light I just I can't get my eyes
off of it like when I see white marble
and stone that's another thing we love
Stone yeah I love Stone white stone for
me it's amazing anything white like when
you pulled up in your car and I just it
I saw like a the bee on the white I
couldn't believe it yes like you know it
was a pleasure to just get in something
right yes that's right yeah so this will
be clipped and it will be used on
Neo-Nazi website yeah by the way it
works Same by the way we're saying white
leather yeah
yeah that's just gonna be I'm talking
about yeah the materials but yes um yeah
no I I really I really love being you
know in sitting in a situation like you
know like I had to fly business I flew
first when I went to uh Grand Rapids but
yeah on the way out here I was in
business and you know I hit the guy's
elbow yeah a little bit and I was like I
just can't do this anymore right you
know Stacy watches Stacy sees the card
though yeah we got into it we got it of
course we got into a thing and and I go
I go look you know I'm making I'm not
making a ton ton of money but I said I'm
making a little money and then she says
listen you gotta rain it in then she
goes listen Paul you know so we got yeah
like you got the LLC right because you
know I gotta because she goes she
actually said to me she goes can we have
a talk tonight yeah because we really
need to talk and she goes can I just can
I just be in charge of the money and I
go look just just you know I'm making
them like let's talk let's talk about it
and she goes Paul you please for me she
goes this might be a big problem for us
she's like because my wife saw that the
foresight was this could be divorce
right so like this would be because
you're gonna go out and you're gonna buy
three pairs of Jordans right and you're
gonna buy first class right and then and
it's great but like we have we have
children that need to get educated yeah
so you got to watch that and you got to
be careful so she looks at it so like
you know today for example I pulled it
to you know I went to the I went to the
mall I got you know I got some press
coming up I got some TV coming up this
week out here so you know I've got to
treat yourself I bought a new pair of
Jordans and I said but then I walked
past another sneaker store I bought
another pair really but here's the thing
I got to send them home I can't pack
them I don't have enough so I'm buying
sneakers and I've got to ship them so
you have two pairs of Jordans on this
trip to your shipping home now I have
five pairs of sneakers on this trip
I got listen to this I have a I have
it's actually crazy like I'm here for
four days it's crazy yeah like yeah so I
got yeah so I I have them and my you're
gonna really laugh my uh luggage has a
section for the actual sneaker boxes I
don't doubt it yeah so I got the
sneakers but then I'm going through and
I see Jordan so I get them and I I saw
another pair but Stacy was watching it
would have another pair would have been
another 500 after I already spent like
six on two pairs so she'll just go so
what did you do she knows she'll
question me how was your day do you do
cash so she doesn't know I mean yeah I
mean sometimes I'll throw a little cash
what did you you know how is this trip
her way to start is how was the trip how
was your flight you know when how was
your flight was like what did you did
you spend right another thing that
changed my life was the Delta Sky Club
changed my life yeah you go to Delta Sky
Club I've never been there you know
here's here's the thing I got to be
honest with you I gotta be honest with
you you Americans you know we had the
British Airways Lounge in London and
like how was that we went to the Qantas
Lounge in Australia here's the reality
American lounges just don't come they
don't compete no you know what the food
I was a little disappointed in the food
at Delta they had like one little hot
thing yeah no dude the Qantas Lounge
that business Lounge it's great it's the
best it was so good and then the Virgin
Lounge too and yeah some of the best
coffee I've ever had oh dude the coffee
the hot cold dishes uh they make uh
grilled cheeses for you like paninis and
stuff that make grilled cheeses they
call them a Toasties uh soup yeah you
know nice rainy day with the soup I mean
you know so I I I respect the Delta Sky
Club no this guy this guy club like was
something where we fly enough where it's
worth it of course a thousand times yeah
but I agree I I heard some of the Delta
ones in the country are like exceptional
yeah but the ones that I went I've been
to a couple and I could have you know to
be honest it could have been a little
better food wise yes it is nice to sit
and listen it's nice to have unlimited
you know it's great I mean that's the
other thing about first class says you
get a meal and the meal is good yeah and
the meal in the back you know I I is
atrocious and like that's the other
thing in in when you are in coach you
were sitting next to people who are
diseased
you know like I mean like ultimately
like because it takes it takes nothing
to be in coach and I've been in coach
and I've been that person who's diseased
like I've gotten on Coach blowing my
note like on the way to hilarities in
Cleveland for a weekend
blowing my nose like
my clothes are in like a ratty backpack
your immune system's worse I'm making
twelve hundred dollars for 17 shows in
Cleveland like it's a nightmare I bring
food and I'm eating like I've been that
person and now and so I know who that
person is and I don't want to be
anywhere near them
do you ever look at the people on the
line for food when you go to the Sky
Lounge and just start laughing out loud
you know what it is I I try to like
sometimes when they walk on the plane to
go back to coach I bless my I bless I go
into silent prayer for them and I go
that's why I ask God bless I hope you
know oh yeah no it's uh but you know
what feels bad what feels bad is if you
if you do first a lot yeah but then like
I said they were just like Paul let me
bumped a thousand do you still want to
do it and I was like with what I was
spending I said no but then walking then
when when you fly first a lot but then
you walk past it because you're not in
it anymore no there's like a feeling of
like I did it one time you know he sits
where do you sit every time and Coach
you said every time I coach and every
time you pass me right that's right I
always pass it and what do I do I always
give you the you point you literally
point back what you purposely like you
just wanna that's like your wife or like
that's just well no he we're not spend
the business pays for his travel when he
comes to New York and stuff we're not
paying you guys don't support him at
first are you mentally ill
this is good turn around turn around
turn around look at yourself whose
name's on the show right there is this a
group show does that say Saturday Night
Live with 65 people in it is this an
ensemble cast that's a very nice I mean
he has a very nice life yeah it does
very well I mean you know do you you
rarely pay for dinner that's true you
know you're very good to me you've been
he's been to the greatest restaurants in
the world in the world in London Nobu
and Malibu he goes in New York we take
him to Don Andrew when they you treat
eating like that's what I noticed about
you and that's what I respect you treat
eating yeah and foods and restaurants
and seafood you do that the way I would
say that like I would do either certain
sneakers or yeah I mean listen I love a
good meal like that but you need like
the like you need meal wise you want the
best right because I used to do drugs
and I miss drugs and I really like drugs
so it's an addictive it's an addictive
personality addictive thing to just say
I want this thing that's hard to get in
and I don't know that we'll be able to
get it and it just reminds me of drugs
because drugs was like oh can we get the
eight ball tonight yeah I want the good
eight ball we want the pink rock you
know the one that's kind of uh how do we
get that well we gotta call him we gotta
drive to [ __ ] Bayside whatever and
this like to me I like to try to get
into the best place because it's a
challenge so whatever yeah so it's like
you'd want a Seafood Tower that like
Prince loved yeah that was delicious
yeah great and that was that's your
eight ball I want the last thing Michael
Jackson ate yeah
I want the last Sushi Pizza in the Geary
he had before he went into a propofol
coma
that's why you know I'll be honest with
you I was on that [ __ ] and that's the
greatest there's nothing there's nothing
better nothing better than come and when
you come out of it yeah there's no mood
better right and if anyone listening
right now if you can get your hands on
Protocol no no that's who's sponsoring
our show Propofol